it's great to be joined today by Tara
Isabella Burton who is the author of
strange writes new religions for a
godless world and the novel social
creature Tara it's so great to have you
on oh thank you so much for having me
I'm delighted to be here so many of us
and many in my audience have seen the
studies that show that adherence to
organized religion and identification as
as religious and as members of
individual religions have declined in
the United States but there's another
sort of side to this which is the idea
of spirituality which can take a lot of
different forms and you talk about ways
in which while sort of more traditional
religiosity is being rejected that we're
not necessarily seeing a decrease in
this broader umbrella of spirituality
can you talk about how spirituality is
different than religiosity and maybe
give us some examples of where we're
seeing it sure so just for a little bit
of background like as you say about a
quarter of Americans identify as
religiously unaffiliated often they
called the N o ne nuns that number goes
up to 36% of Americans born after 1985
so we're talking about a huge proportion
of particularly millennial and younger
population the however that doesn't mean
as you say that they're not interested
in spirituality and spirituality at
least as I understand it and as I work
on it and my book is about sort of
various elements of religious life
unbundled you might say divorced from
organized religion which which is itself
about so much more than just personal
belief organized religion and indeed any
religion you might say has sort of a
component that is belief and Dogma a
search for meaning individual purpose
but also community understanding of a
kind of social place and the rituals
that kind of bind that community
together and what we're seeing isn't
necessarily some that spirituality is
somehow different from organized
religion and offering those different
things but often that we find people
young Americans in particular more
willing to find these different
components of religious life from
variety of sources someone might for
example still go to like Christmas and
Easter services or various High Holy
Days with their families a couple times
a year
have a sense of community from a hobby
that they do also practice meditation or
yoga kind of privately and really just
creating their own religion rather than
sort of adopting wholesale the model of
an existing organized tradition so
what's the difference between some of
what you describe and just a lifestyle
in the sense that I mean one could
imagine that one finds for example
veganism yoga and bicycling to be sort
of related to the values that they
exhibit and dealing with the problems
they most acutely identify as needing
solutions or whatever how do we how
would we distinguish that from whether
it is a lifestyle whether it has a sort
of spiritual istic component whether it
is more religious what are the lines or
or maybe it's a gray area
so I actually think it is a gray area I
think it's almost impossible to actually
have a working definition of religion
you see this actually in other areas
where people are often sort of talking
about cults what makes a cult versus a
quote-unquote normal religion the lines
are blurry I sometimes I joke it's like
porn you know it when you see it but at
the same time even within sort of
academic definitions of religion like
there are as many definitions of
religion as there are scholars of
religion and my book I talk about sort
of Durkheim or Clifford Geertz all of
whom see religion is completely
different it's about belief no it's
about a society no it's about symbols
and sort of a shared understanding all
of these things are also true more
broadly so I think a useful way to think
about it is not kind of is this a
religion is it not a religion but
looking at the ways in which organized
religions have traditionally been kind
of transmission vectors or places for a
lot of the components of religious life
all at once you know your your sense of
meaning your sense of purpose your sense
of community and your sense of ritual
largely coming from one place this was
all the more
when for example where you were shipped
on Sunday or any other day of the week
for that matter would also be where you
met people you were most likely to
perhaps form a relationship and marry
and have children with a community that
sort of supported you through your
various life stages your values your
sense of ritual your sense of meaning
and purpose we're tied up and I say
you're a sort of traditionally in
America more broadly like sort of this
stereotype of the 1950s where what
church you get went to was a sort of by
word for a whole other host of social
associations and that's really what
we've lost and the quote-unquote
spiritual but not religious or secular
age rather than belief or interest in
the metaphysical or the divine well
thinking earlier than the 1950s in
earlier human history there was a time
which I find very interesting where but
membership in a religious group actually
conferred an evolutionary advantage in
the sense that you you were far more
likely if you got along with the people
around you than if you didn't to survive
and to have enough food to eat and to go
on to have children and and you know
procreate and pass on your genes that
element of religion has dramatically
diminished certainly we could probably
find some places in the world where it
exists but but in modern Western world
that that's not a factor I'm interested
in whether youth you see the sort of
modern lifestyle slash spirituality
vectors having some component of that
advantage in society maybe not literally
to our survival but to some degree of
prospering maybe yes I mean yes and no
and what I mean by that is
simultaneously I think that the kind of
new tribalism that we formed through
various affiliations often by as
distinct from religions into which we
were often born are determined by choice
you know we are part of this group or
that group our interest in CrossFit you
know or or what-have-you gives us a sort
of family we choose in a very particular
way at the same time though I think that
so much of the way in which the sort of
contemporaries
reality works is through a quite
individualized model we basically each
make our own religion in that way and I
say we soar more broadly but
particularly young Americans tend to be
more likely to mix and match even and
this isn't exclusive to people who call
themselves religious nuns there was a
2018 pew study that found that about 30
percent of self-identified Christians
also said like I believe in
reincarnation about a similar number
said they believe in psychics astrology
things that are not traditionally
understood within the Orthodox Christian
umbrella we're seeing more broadly a
willingness on the part of both the
religious traditionally religious and
the unaffiliated to kind of create
through through choice through what they
buy the classes they take it's often a
very sort of consumerist choice their
own soar spiritual identity especially
in a internet-based capitalist world
such as we are in that often means
voting with your dollars kind of
consuming as a form of creating you know
do you buy the Sephirah which kit which
has its starter pack of tarot cards
which was for a while available on kind
of the the high street until it was
actually withdrawn over a bit of
controversy do you spend your money on a
yoga class or meditation app and I think
the way in which we've become sort of
more atomized more individual in part
because of this sort of obsession with
our own choices our own affinities has
made perhaps this iteration of
spirituality a little bit less group
focused I would say then religion as
traditionally understood well one of the
interesting things that you mentioned
gets into some of the examples that
relate to one of the characteristics
that's often present in certainly the
more devout areas of the traditional
religions is that there's not a very
strong sort of error-correcting
mechanism the way science has we're
questioning the beliefs and changing the
beliefs is is welcomed a lot of times
the community leader and more
established religious religions
welcome people coming in and saying I
think that you're actually wrong about
this that the other thing and saying hey
we made a mistake let's change what the
what the Scriptures are that's often not
encouraged and sorry when I look at some
of the modern ways in which we might
explore spirituality or religion I I
sort of pay attention to that and so for
example I had an experience with the
followers of this gentleman named Jordan
Peterson a couple of years ago where
there were a lot of examples of when I
would critique something he said or did
there was a sort of post hoc
rationalization of your misunderstand
you you have to be misunderstanding what
he said and therefore your critique is
not accurate or another example might be
either you know Flat Earth or astrology
where you might try to say hey let's try
to apply some critical thinking and the
idea of revising the dogma as it maybe
is not at all welcomed is that the case
in a lot of these spirituality outlets
that you look at not in a lot how
present is that it's present but I'd say
in a slightly different form which is to
say often these groups or rather that
these practices as instantiated in
individuals have come up in part because
they're sort of we have such a profound
public distrust now in institutions
there is a sort of you know particularly
religious institutions from sex abuse
scandals to the political alliance of
particularly white of angelical
Christianity with the GOP to say nothing
of sort of the broader failures of
institutions we see whether it's sort of
the dissents of the media or politics or
what have you there is I would argue a
widespread sense that because
institutions have failed we can no
longer trust them what do you do when
you can't trust an institution when you
can't trust science or you think you
can't trust science or journalists or
the establishment you turn it inwards
there's a sense in which it is sort of
similarly perhaps it is I don't want to
say anti intellectual perhaps that's too
strong but intuitional there are a lot
of these movements from wellness culture
to to an extent even some of the
followers of Jordan Peterson in a
certain way although he is a sort of
leader which adds a different dimension
but the ideas that you focus you turn
inward you focus on yourself which is
what you can control and what you can
rely on and I think that that you often
find that in a lot of the conspiracy
theorists and even the way that a lot of
like jordan peterson fans will sort of
talk about him versus the sort of the pc
establishment that's hiding truths from
you there is a very much an
anti-establishment anti institutional
strain to a lot of these beliefs and so
i think on the one hand there's a
rejection of kind of dogma in the
abstract as something that institutions
do that we don't want to sort of succumb
to and yet there is also a resistance to
for example in the case of like wellness
culture you know not a very few of the
scientific facts on quite at the
Paltrow's website goop are we might say
they are not always fact checked to the
fullest extent and indeed they I think
gotten quite a bit of trouble over that
but I think the narrative goes something
like well like this feels true and it's
completely understandable that when a
person might think that none of the
authorities around them are worth
listening to they can't rely on them
suddenly you know like going with your
gut there are worse things you can do I
I'm interested in talking a little bit
about the protests we've seen over the
last couple of weeks protests that I
white widely support the the objectives
of and and which I'm sympathetic to I've
seen some examples I don't have you know
feel the need to say this is a lot or
not a lot but I've seen examples of
would seem almost like pseudo religious
types of moments where black people in
large groups are I'm sorry white people
in large groups apologize to black
people for their privilege or calls for
white people to give the black people at
the protest money in some kind of
symbolic reparations that things that
things that to me start to feel a little
bit cult-like and that they go beyond
sort of the activism component to it how
should we be applying this religiosity
spirituality analysis to the movement
we're seeing take hold over the last
couple of weeks sure I think speaking
more broadly
about the social justice we've been as I
do in the book I mean I think it's
absolutely right to apply this scholar
of religions lens or the religious lens
to it and I think that when people often
do that sort of it's often a charge that
is leveled against the social justice
movement from those right
you know there's elet's they're a
religion they're a cult etc I'd like to
sort of say that you know something of a
bit more complicated which is that yes
it is religious in nature that is both
as with any any movement the good and
the bad of it which is to say I think
the the sense of hope the sense of
profundity the sense that this is
meaningful that there is a a better
world at the end of all this which is
you know quite striking I think in our
some somewhat alienated capitalist world
one might say there aren't that many
places for not just the sacred or
enchantment but a vision of that
enchantment that is linked up with a
vision of the world how its it should be
things like wellness culture are very
individualistic as I've said you know
you great you can you can achieve a sort
of enlightenment its soul cycle but it
begins and ends with you and I think
that it's absolutely right to talk about
the kind of symbolism the sense of
catharsis the collective effervescence
as Dirk I might say that you might find
in a protest movement as being in
religious and nature but I think that's
why it's that's what I would say that's
why it's been so successful so
widespread precisely because it is able
to harness a kind of religious longing
this is not just a group of people
protesting it is people sort of getting
in touch with a perhaps not a divine
purpose but a sort of fundamentally real
purpose to change the world to make it
better or certainly a purpose that's
bigger than them yes absolutely
absolutely and I think it brings it both
brings people together which especially
after however many months of isolation I
think is all the more appealing and it
provides a framework to kind of see in a
world that could very well see
meaningless and chaotic some form not
just
in the abstract but but purpose what one
person's individual life individual
choices to to protest to to get involved
how that might link up with a kind of
grander cosmic bigger than them scale so
I think that it's absolutely right to
think about it in terms of religion but
also sort of the question to ask us not
like are they a religion and therefore
should it be sort of discounted as
irrational but rather as a religion what
is this offering that other forms of
living in 2020 aren't necessarily
offering know how what why is this so
meaningful and compelling very very
interesting we've been speaking with
Tara Isabella Burton who's author of
strange rights new religions for a
godless world and also author of the
novel social creature Tara so great
having you on I really appreciate it
thank you so much it was lovely